- I've been telling this joke
at my stand-up which I told on,
I don't know how dirty we can get.
- You can get as dirty as you want.
(serene electronic music)
This is "The Rubin Report"
and I'm still Dave Rubin.
Before we do anything else,
today, we have officially launched
"The Rubin Report" community
in the Apple App Store,
Google Play, and at RubinReport.com.
But more importantly than that,
joining me today is comedian, podcaster,
and now star of the new
documentary "No Safe Spaces",
which is in theaters as of today
where we're taping this
right now, Adam Carolla.
Welcome to "The Rubin Report".
- Thank you, Dave.
- Good to have you here.
- Yeah.
- You do a lot of this--
- I'm a fan of yours.
- Well, I'm a fan of yours,
but you do a lot of this the other way.
You interview people all the time.
- I do, and I enjoy being interviewed.
- [Dave] Which do you like more?
- It's like, well, what do
you like more: pizza or sushi?
Well, when you eat a metric
ton of pizza every month,
you're dying for a California roll.
- [Dave] So this is your California roll?
- Yeah, it's not that one
is better than the other,
it's like all I do is
interview, interview, interview,
and I like it when it's swapped.
I also had this revelation
the other day which is I
used to say to Dr. Drew,
what you do is easy,
when we do these shows,
we'd be guests on shows,
and we do college campuses,
and we do whatever.
And I realized when I had to be funny,
it was a calorie burner.
And so what happened was,
but my comparison or contrast was this:
I've done a million radio,
25 stations, you're
gonna talk to 25 stations
over the next three hours,
and it's a press junket yeah.
And when I do one for my
book or a comedy that I'm in
or something of a comedic nature,
at the end of the three hours,
I'm exhausted because I'm trying
to be funny the whole time
because it's a comedy book,
I'm telling 'em jokes in the book,
I want them to think I'm
funny so the book is funny.
- You gotta keep yourself entertained too.
- Yes, although I don't
care about myself that much,
but yes, I do,
but the last one I did
was over documentary,
not "No Safe Spaces" but
my "Ford v Ferrari" doc
which was Shelby American
and the 24-hour war,
and all I was doing is
talking cars the whole time
and shopped the whole time,
and I was fresh as a daisy
after the three hours
because I realized I was
talking about stuff I knew,
whereas Dr. Drew gets
to talk about medicine.
If we just talked about carpentry or cars,
I wouldn't be exhausted.
If I'm spinning the comedic
plates, it gets tiring.
- What level of energy
do you have right now
for me to gauge how we should
do this interview then?
- I never wanna disappoint you,
or your fans or your
viewers, so I'm putting out.
- All right.
Well, we'll do a little
bit on the stuff you know
and a little bit on the
stuff you pretend to know.
How about that?
- All up to you.
- But you kinda do do a zillion things
because you consider yourself
a comic first, right?
- Yes.
- So you're a comic, you're a podcaster,
documentaries, reality shows.
Do you enjoy them all the same
or it's just whatever you do?
- I wanna do whatever's next.
I think what makes a bad job
for a bad job is monotony, repetition.
If you have a job where you go
I work at a medium-sized
technology company
and you go, okay, that sounds okay.
But if you said to someone,
I have a job where I
work at a conveyor belt
and I just put the heads on
dolls and they just keep,
it sounds horrible
because it's the monotony.
So if you think about it,
even hosting a late-night
show for 30 years
is still monotony within a good job.
What most people don't
like is when they go,
he went to the same postal sorting center
in Arleta for 50 years and then he died,
everyone's feelings goes,
well, what a boring life,
what a crappy life.
So for me, doing a car doc,
doing a free-speech doc, doing a podcast,
writing a book, being in a
TV show or whatever it is,
it's all just variety and
that's all I wanna do.
- So we're obviously
gonna talk a lot about "No Safe Spaces",
but your podcast, you were
early in on the podcast game,
and your podcast,
is it basically the biggest
talk comedy podcast?
You and Rogen, it's hard
to tell who's bigger.
Do you know or are you
measuring that everyday?
- I don't know.
- Looking at the numbers?
- He's bigger on iTunes
but we don't get so much of
our listeners from iTunes,
so I don't know.
I'll just say he's bigger,
I'll be magnanimous.
We're the Guinness Book of
World Records downloaded,
so that much I know.
That was some years ago so.
- Do you remember the moment
when you wanted to make that
pivot to the digital thing?
'Cause I saw a lot of comics
get all kinds of crossed-up,
people that had really promising careers
that still want it to go
into TV or traditional radio,
and then a lot other
guys were like no, no,
there's something else brewing here,
and then they really
started flourishing online.
I think I went that route,
which is what we're doing here.
- I had a terrestrial
radio job for many years,
maybe almost 15 years
of terrestrial radio straight through
that ended abruptly.
I was only interested in
keeping a communication line
between me and my audience,
and not all of my audience,
just some of my audience.
I was always a big fan of talk radio,
I was appreciated the format.
I always liked the connection
that I felt like the listeners
were having with the hosts.
I always knew it was deeper
because there was a sense of loss
that transcended your favorite
sitcom going off the air,
last episode of "Friends",
last episode of "Seinfeld".
People are like, oh, last
episode of "Breaking Bad".
I wish it was still in the air
but when somebody like
Howard Stern hangs it up
or folks of that ilk,
there's gonna be a big
sense of loss for people,
and not just entertainment
loss, emotional loss.
So I had been doing "Loveline"
and doing a morning show
with no commercials and a lot of talk,
and I felt like I had an
audience and I had a connection.
And when my show ceased on a Friday,
I just said, to whoever is listening,
if you wanna come with
me to the digital world,
you may find me.
And I'm assuming most of you aren't
because you're in the car
and it's going to dial,
and you're being passive.
And so if you're not,
you're not, that's fine,
but that doesn't mean you need me,
it means you don't care that much.
But for the few that do wanna
keep going down this road,
I can be found on the
internet, come Monday.
We won't skip a day.
I'll stop on a Friday,
you'll have me waiting for you on Monday.
I'm not sure what form exactly yet
but you will get me
and then we will try to
move forward from there.
And that was really my only concern.
There was no monetization
that I was aware of back then.
It was just let's keep the connection
because it does feel like a death.
And I know from listening to
talk radio as a young person,
when somebody finally signs
off or goes off the air,
I'm like, ah, I liked that guy.
- (laughs) Right, right, right there.
And in the old days' radio,
you were just gone at that point.
You were just gone.
- You would've just been gone.
So I have not missed a day since that date
which was I think the 23rd of February,
2009 or something.
- So you really were early on this,
and I remember the first
time I did your show
when I walked into your studio over there.
I was like, holy cow.
It was before I had my
home studio and everything.
And I was like, holy cow,
this guy actually has
a building and staff,
and it's professional,
and there's an area to
hang out and coffee,
and all your posters and everything.
I was like, oh, you can
really do this on your own,
which for me, it was like,
whoa, all right, great,
there's a path here.
- Well, you're welcome.
- So thank you! (laughs)
- We'll clean that up in post.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, no post here.
See, I'm not as professional, no post.
- We're supposed to borrow it.
- No post.
- All right.
So I had this radio mind,
I had this thought where
you wanna do a show,
you need a producer if
you're doing a show,
you need a sound guy.
You can't just completely mom-and-pop this
and expect to get the product
that you want day in and day out.
You want some production.
So my earliest thoughts
were I didn't have,
like I'm betting on myself
or I know this is gonna be
bigger than Uber in five years,
or I didn't have any of that.
I just had I know how radio works,
I don't see why this is
different than radio,
I don't know why we would
treat it any different.
We should have a staff,
we should have a studio,
the equipment should be good,
don't be scared to spend
some money to get money,
you're gonna have to spend it
to make some like any business,
and furthermore, I was like,
if clients are coming in
or potential supporters
or potential folks are gonna
buy ad time or whatever it is,
they should walk into a building
that looks like their
money's going somewhere.
It's that thing of you
don't want your contractor,
and I know that's a sore subject today,
but your contractor--
- We're having a little
contracting issue at the moment.
It's okay, it's okay.
- Your contractor pulls up
in a total rust bucket beater
and then wants to charge you a premium,
you're like, look at your truck?
You know what I mean?
So my thing is get a nice truck,
get a nice bed box, get a lumber rack,
tuck your shirt in,
look like you're a good
contractor and then charge,
then go ahead and gouge the elderly.
- You're like the Jordan Peterson
of contractors, basically.
- Right.
- You're telling them to clean their room.
You must be very impressed
with my lighting grid though.
- It is.
- I mean, come on,
that is a professional expensive
lighting grid right there.
- It really is.
It really is nice.
- You'll love this, the guy who
hung this whole entire grid,
which these are huge, you can imagine
how heavy all these
poles are and everything,
I didn't know who he was,
I got referred to him by a friend.
The guy shows up by that door,
he's about 60 years
old, I swear on my life,
his arm's in a sling,
he's wearing a Tommy Bahama
shirt and flip-flops,
he goes, "I'm Joe, I'm
here to hang the grid."
And he did this entire thing basically
with one arm and flip-flops,
15-foot high ceilings
with a system of pulleys
that he created with one arm.
- Wow!
- It was on a 15-foot ladder
with flip-flops, 60-year-old guy.
It was incredible.
- People don't realize--
- So people work hard.
- Listen, I come from
the construction world
so I understand working hard,
and I also understand
the number one killer of
men over 60 are ladders.
They--
- Ladders and flip-flops?
- Ladders and flip-flops.
It's not a good combination.
- All right, let's talk about
this movie, "No Safe Spaces"
'cause I felt, when I watched
it a couple weeks ago,
I went to the premiere here in L.A.,
and you were there and you
did this with Dennis Prager,
and Jordan Peterson was in it,
and Lindsay Shepherd was in it,
and Bret Weinstein was in it,
and Heather Heying was in it,
basically, I felt it was like
a Rubin Report reunion show.
I was very pleased.
But there was one guy in it
that I thought was really incredible,
and I wanna just throw it to a clip.
There's a reason that every time
one of these professors or TAs,
whether it's Lindsay Shepherd in Canada
or Bret Weinstein in Washington,
why are they all Lefties
who then say one thing
that upsets the Left
and then they're purged?
It will come for you.
If there's someone that's
watching this right now
that is a hardcore progressive,
that's going, man, I
hate Prager and Rubin,
and this is all nonsense, guess what?
If you have any spark
of individualism in you,
if you have anything about you
that's interesting or different,
they will come to destroy that too.
That guy is incredible.
- Yeah, he's got it.
- It? It!
- I'm sure they're gonna spin that guy off
and do his own series.
There's no way.
They continued down this path
with Prager and Corolla
when they got that.
- Yeah.
Why did you do this movie?
Where'd this all come from?
- Contrary to popular anything, for me,
as we're discussing off the
air, I like experiences.
And the answer is usually yes.
People say to me, why did you
do "Dancing with the Stars"?
I'm like, "They asked."
And like, "Yeah, but what
made you want to do?"
And I go, "'Cause they asked."
and I just went, oh, well, actually,
with "Dancing with the Stars",
they asked me if I wanted to do it
and I thought, oh, I'm scared.
My first impulse was like,
it's like Bobby Hinton wants
to see you in the alley
after the seventh grade
and you went oh, oh my god, I'm scared!
I'm scared and then you realized,
oh, I have to fight 'cause I'm scared.
That's what I felt.
And I like Prager.
I've had a chance to travel
around, play some colleges,
or do some events with him.
Prager is a great guy
just to kick around with
'cause he has all the
wisdom and the knowledge
but in this jovial Uncle Joe
from Petticoat Junction fun way
but also is this fountain
of wisdom and knowledge
and there's really no better guy.
I have been lucky in that
hanging out with Jimmy Kimmel,
hanging out with Dr. Drew,
hanging out with Dennis Prager,
just sitting next to 'em on a long flight
or something like,
there's no better guys
to just talk or laugh
or exchange ideas with.
All different but they're great.
And I love that.
I love sitting with someone
and just hearing their ideas
and sharing ideas.
So when they said we wanna do this movie,
and Dennis Prager's doing it,
I was just kinda like, oh, good!
More time to hang out with Dennis Prager.
I like the theme.
If you say to me we
want you to be involved
with this product or project
and we're not gonna tell you what to say,
you give your opinions
on stuff, I'm usually in.
I'm usually in if you go
say whatever you want.
If you say we're doing this project,
here's a script, memorize
it, regurgitate it,
I'm usually like, ah, I'm
not that interested in that.
But you're gonna sit with Prager,
we're gonna bring up subjects,
you guys are gonna
tag-team those subjects.
And I'm like, oh, I'm in.
- So the movie mostly is about
the college campus upheaval
that's going on right now.
Do you remember when you first were aware
that there was the problem?
- I was hearing from other comedians
that they didn't wanna
go to college campuses,
like anyone seeing in the news
when people were going to
speak at college campuses
and unable to speak,
I live in this world where
it's mostly comedy world.
So I have this bizarre world
where I'm good friends
with Sarah Silverman
but I'm also friends with Ben Shapiro.
So I would hear these bits and pieces,
and people saying to me,
I remember backstage of The Comedy Store,
Sarah said to me,
"Your joke, that joke,
that black joke you have,"
she's like, "So funny.
"Too bad you can't do it."
And I was like, oh, that sucked.
It's weird that comedians are
saying to other comedians,
like, hey, it's a great joke,
too bad you can't do it.
- What do you really make of that though?
So I'm not a fan of Sarah's.
I've invited her on the show many times.
I don't wanna make this about
your friends specifically
so you don't have to
answer directly to her,
but there's a series of comics now
that were really politically
incorrect back in the day.
She's been in blackface, right?
Jimmy Kimmel's been in blackface.
I don't think either
one of them are racist
but by the rules that the Left is setting
which they are about those rules,
now she's saying to you,
oh, don't make that black joke anymore,
and there's a lot of that
happening with comics,
and I never would have
expected that with comedians.
- Well, if you think about comedians,
(laughs) the thing about comedians,
at their core, they wanna be loved.
You're standing on stage
saying like, please.
- [Dave] Love me!
- Please love me, you know what I mean?
They weren't the most popular kids,
they weren't jocks in high school.
If you think about why are comedians,
they're very sensitive
which is counterintuitive.
Jeff Ross, The Roastmaster,
he's a super sensitive guy.
And I don't mean that in a weak way
but he's nothing like The Roastmaster.
He's a sweet, sensitive guy.
Many comedians are sensitive.
Many comedians wanna be loved.
Many actors wanna be loved.
That's the profession.
They're not taking the job
of staff sergeant or foreman.
They have a job that goes
like, please accept me,
please love me,
so when these matters come down the pike,
they're, oh, what would get people
to love me and accept me and embrace me
and send out positive
tweets and vibes and stuff?
So they are wrestling with this duality
of I speak my mind, I tell it like it is,
I take no prisoners, please
love me, please love me!
- Yeah, that's a freaking fine line.
- That's a pretty weird fine line.
My thing has always been
I know I'm not an asshole
so I am now free to act like an asshole.
My whole thing is I know
I'm not a bad person
so I can say whatever I want.
It's basically this.
If you have friends who
you know they love you
and you know you love them,
then you let the ballbusting begin.
If you have somebody, if you
think about it psychologically,
there's that person.
There's always that one person at work
where there's five of
you wanna go to lunch,
and then there's Andy,
and you don't really want
Andy to come with you
but if Andy ever catches wind,
you have to overcompensate,
like, oh, Andy, come on, dude!
And then he's going, I don't know,
I think I'm just gonna eat at my desk.
And everyone goes,
it wouldn't be lunch without you, brother!
And it's like what they're doing
is they all feel weird and bad
for not wanting to be there
that they actually go the other way.
But if you love Andy and
Andy loves you, then you go,
we'll get you a burger and bring it back.
Maybe I'll take a bite out of it,
and then he laughs, and then you laugh,
and then he ends up going.
But I feel that way about making fun
of groups or races or
individuals or anything.
You have some darkness in your heart.
I always say you know how
you know I'm not racist?
I make so many racist jokes.
If I was racist, I'd be like,
I don't make anymore racist
jokes, then we're onto you.
- Do you think there's some
element of it though with comics
where it's like the ones that have done
some of that stuff in the past,
now, it's like they have to pay penance
to make sure that their
past doesn't destroy them,
where you're saying you're guilt-free
because you've done some stuff.
Do you ever worry
that they're gonna go back
in "The Man Show" clips
and be, oh, he hates women
or any of this kinda stuff,
but what they're doing
is a more dangerous game
because again, I don't wanna make it
about those two people specifically
but there's a series of
comics now and public people
that are calling everyone
racists and bigots
and all the Conservatives are bad guys.
You know what I'm talking about, right?
And it's like, well, you
guys used to do that stuff.
It strikes me as just it's
just self-preservation.
I get the emotionally damaged part
but it just strikes me as
it's just business in a way.
- Well, look, it is a business in that.
It's a business where we
don't need Matt Lauer.
- Let me put it like this.
Sorry to interrupt, but
let me put it this way.
So if you showed up,
if there was a thing that 20 years ago,
you showed up in blackface,
I don't think you would get
the pass that Kimmel's gotten
because Kimmel is a big Lefty now,
he's a Hollywood Lefty, so he gets a pass,
where you're more libertarian Conservative
or just out there.
Now, you're also
self-funded so that helps.
You're your own boss so that's good
but you wouldn't get the
pass, do you agree with that?
- Here's my take on it.
I think they go where the getting's good.
So they're basically feral cats
looking for a saucer of milk.
And if you don't put it out on the porch,
they'll keep going.
People don't really bother me
even though I say horrible things,
and not horrible things by my definition
but by their definition.
I do have a picture of me in blackface.
It's going as Mr. T for Halloween in 1985.
I put it out there.
I'm like, look, listen,
this isn't blackface, this is Mr. T.
That's not blackface.
That's a minstrel show.
This is me dressing like Mr. T
because I'm a fan of Mr. T's.
So this is a--
- Which that's the normal, thoughtful way
of dealing with this, of course.
You weren't doing it to mock the guy,
you were doing it out
of admiration and love.
- Right.
And you would like to take it
and contort it and twist it into blackface
which is general generic
make fun of black people vaudeville stuff.
This is not that.
So first things first,
I'm not signing off on your
definition of what I did.
I dressed up as Mr. T.
Mr. T is black, I went with a black face,
which is not blackface,
it's me dressing as Mr. T.
And furthermore, I'm not
apologizing to anybody about it.
And if you talk to Mr. T,
I bet he would be happy
that a bunch of kids
dressed like him in 1985
and said, "I pity the fool."
over and over again at
a Halloween party so.
- I used to buy Mr. T cereal.
That's far worse than
doing blackface of Mr. T.
- You consumed Mr. T.
So I think with me,
there's no job to remove me from per se.
And then also, I don't apologize.
The other thing is I don't let
or I attempt not to let
people create this narrative
and create this theme
which is there's a
picture of you with black,
it wasn't paint.
I think I took a toilet paper
roll and burnt the end of it
and then smeared that soot on my face.
But there's a picture of you in blackface,
and I go no, no, there's a
picture of me dressed like Mr. T.
And they go, in blackface.
I go, not blackface,
that's a different genre.
This is Mr. T.
That's from the '40s or the '30s.
This is from '80s.
But you still.
I go, I was dressed as Mr. T.
It's an homage to the man.
And what do you want me to do about it?
I'll put every picture up on
the internet, I don't care.
- Yeah.
Are you fascinated how it hits every comic
no matter how vanilla they are?
There's a moment,
it's in the movie about
Seinfeld telling this story
about doing a college gig
and he does a joke about, what is it,
a gay British king or something?
- [Adam] Maybe a French king.
- A French King with a loose hand
and he said he did this joke
and the kids basically,
it's like five years ago,
the kids basically groaned.
And it's Seinfeld who I
love Jerry's stand-up,
the show is the greatest sitcom ever.
It's like I don't know
any of his political beliefs on anything.
He is so guarded what his
actual political beliefs are,
and he does this silly joke
about a French king's hand
and that's even too politically incorrect
for these students.
Yeah, it's funny.
It's kinda interesting
'cause I do know a lot of these comedians
and we all know our actors,
our Hollywood community,
I've now figured it out
where you went like,
well, I know Sarah Silverman
and Mark Ruffalo and Alyssa Milano,
I know their politics,
and you go, but I don't know
Jerry Seinfeld's politics,
or I don't know Jay Leno's politics.
I go--
- Ah, now I--
- My new law and order is
just when you don't know.
- Oh!
- Go ahead and check
the Republican box because my new theory,
I started thinking about,
and I have some insider
trading information here.
I'm like, how come everyone else
is out there blasting it out
from the highest mountain?
When you're on the Left
and you're not playing it close
to the vest like a Morano.
It's a Dennis Prager reference.
But the the Jews of Spain who are like,
don't let anyone find,
if you are backing Bernie or
Elizabeth Warren or whatever
and you're in the Hollywood community,
you have a bullhorn and
you're on a mountaintop.
So if you really just
kinda do the reverse math,
who are the people
whose politics you're
completely unaware of
and you've never heard
'em speak a word about it,
you must go, hmm, how
come I've never heard,
how come I've never seen 'em in a rally,
a women's rally or marching on
or sending a tweet out about,
and you go, I'm gonna do
a reverse math on that.
- So you're saying Seinfeld
ain't voting for Bernie.
- I think the guys who
you hear nothing about
have a leaning that's
probably a little less Bernie
and probably a little more Trump.
- Do you miss the days when not
everything was so political?
'Cause that also is
what this movie is about
and that politics has now leaked
into every part of society all the time.
So it's like you just mentioned Leno
and it's like back in the day,
I never really liked Leno
'cause I didn't know what
he thought about anything.
And in a weird way, I miss that now.
I don't watch any of
those Late Night shows,
but every night, when you
see clips on Twitter of,
I can't even think of who's the host.
Who's the--
- Fallon, Jimmy Kimmel.
- Fallon,
and who's the other one?
- Colbert.
- The NBC one?
The other guy.
- [Both] Seth Meyers.
- It's like they're just railing on Trump.
It's the same thing
every night over and over
where it's so political all the time,
and it's made me miss the day
that Leno would just go
up there and (mumbles),
and it was just like he
was just doing this thing
that was for everybody.
- Yeah.
I think there's an element
of a saturation point.
You did want Leno back in the day
to dig into more substantive issues
or reveal a little more
of himself and all that.
And Jay, who I know really well,
is always realized that
this is a marathon
and it's not a sprint.
- I respect that now.
I regret I was hard on him for years
when I was doing standup,
and I regret it actually.
- And I think he's realized that no good
could come from him.
I believe there's some
old-school comedians who go,
you're not supposed to know me.
You're supposed to know my jokes.
I'm gonna let my jokes do my talking.
I don't want the distraction
of you knowing I'm Republican or Democrat,
or gay or straight, or anything.
I don't want anything bleeding
into these jokes I'm gonna lay over you.
But also, when you take a stand
as a Patriots fan and
you let the world know
you're the number one Patriot fan.
The Patriots are capable of
then spending a decade lose it.
Why declare a major when the
next person could get voted in
and this thing could swing
like the other direction?
It seems like you're putting
your career needlessly in jeopardy.
- That's crazy for a comic,
that truth-telling thing
and the like thing,
they can often just be
at odds with each other.
- Yeah.
I do think that many people,
many comedians, as you know,
just have a different approach to comedy.
And also, there's an element
of you live in Hollywood,
you have a job,
I've been telling this joke at my standup
which I told on,
I don't know how dirty we can get.
- You can get as dirty as you want.
- I told this joke when
we were doing the--
- You wanna get in
blackface for this one or?
- With a roast.
(both laughing)
- I got a guy with some
charcoal back there.
- We were doing a roast on
Comedy Central for Alec Baldwin.
Larry David was sitting in the front row,
and he literally on the commercial
break came over and went,
"That's the funniest
thing I've ever heard."
That was the greatest moment
of my life 'cause I love--
- That's pretty.
- [Both] Pretty, pretty good.
- He literally, then I was like,
he was like, "That joke, I love it."
It's a very Larry David joke,
and it's also totally
politically incorrect.
But it is here to illustrate
that when I was a carpenter,
or guys who do fabrication work
and can shape metal into any shape,
or a guy in flip-flops with one arm
who can hang a lighting grid,
it doesn't really matter
what his politics are,
we can't run 'em out.
We can't go, no more
lighting grid work for you,
or hey man, if you're
a journeyman carpenter,
if you're a good carpenter,
you can't be drummed out.
There's too many people who need you.
If you're an actor,
look, Matt Lauer made $30 million a year,
now Matt Lauer makes nothing.
Does anyone miss Matt Lauer?
- Right.
- And we don't need Matt Lauer.
We didn't need Billy Bush.
We can just knock out and
go with somebody else.
We don't need you.
And that's kinda scary.
You live in a town where
the journeyman carpenter,
they don't have to worry
what they talk about.
But an actor, you could get
tossed out of this club.
And the joke was I had Alec
Baldwin sitting over here
and I had Robert De Niro
sitting next to him,
and I said, "Two of the
finest actors in America.
"What amazing craft and an
ability, unbelievable ability.
"Look at the two of you!
"Maybe the two greatest ever.
"I have so much respect for you."
After hearing about the whole
Harvey Weinstein situation
and hearing a lot of those stories,
I don't know if I have such high respect
for the craft of acting anymore.
What other job works this way?
You wanna be a commercial airline pilot,
blow that fat joke.
They'll have you up in
the air this afternoon.
You wanna be a dental hygienist?
Blow the fat joke,
more than likely, you'll start tomorrow.
(Dave laughs)
I was making the joke that
maybe acting is not as hard.
- [Dave] I think that proves your point.
- Right.
So actors are in a precarious situation.
Now, Dave Chappelle isn't.
Dave Chappelle's a journeyman carpenter,
but Matt Lauer reads a teleprompter,
and many actors could be replaced by
whenever they do those things,
or you know who was gonna play
the original Indiana Jones
and you go, oh, there was gonna be--
- Nic Cage?
- I don't know,
the original 007 was gonna be?
Right, right, you're
gonna see and you realize,
they live in a world
where someone else could just
take their job the next day
and we're not really gonna miss 'em,
so you gotta follow the party line.
- It's interesting that
you bring up Chappelle
because you're basically
saying a guy like him
who has just relentlessly
fought the system,
his bravery is what now protects him.
Which that is a theme
throughout the movie too,
that all of the people
that I mentioned earlier
from Bret and Lindsay and
Jordan, who else is in there?
- Oh, well--
- Everybody's in there.
You had--
- But there's Van Jones.
- Van Jones, yeah.
- And there's Dershowitz.
- So that's interesting
'cause you guys make a point,
and this is the part that I'm in,
you make a point of saying
that there are a couple Liberals left.
Did you feel like that was a
point you really had to hit,
otherwise you would just be seen
as a couple good Liberals left,
as opposed to just saying,
well then, we're just making
a Conservative movie here
or something like?
- I think there's a catch to it
where someone will say,
and then there's obviously
been this critique,
you're only highlighting
Right-leaning speakers
or Conservative speakers
who are being shouted
off the college campuses.
You're only highlighting
the Ben Shapiros and the Ann Coulters.
And the answer is 'cause
they don't shout off,
and they don't shout
out Left-leaning ones.
So this is a weird thing
you're asking us to do.
Be more even-handed.
Well, if Rachel Maddow went to Berkeley,
there wouldn't be fires
in the parking lot.
- Yeah.
You mean it wouldn't cost, what was it?
Was it three or 600,000 to
secure that Shapiro event?
I believe--
- I think it was 600,000.
- I think it was six.
I think it was six.
- No, so,
this thing of we only highlight this.
Well, it's like, those are the
only people who get protested
so if you're gonna highlight protests,
then unfortunately, it's
only gonna be from that side.
We've had conversations.
We don't want this to come across
as some Right-wing tutorial.
- Yeah, and it does.
I mean, it does not.
- We wanted the Van Joneses
and the Cornel Wests and
the Alan Dershowitz' eye,
and many people from all sides
and everything in between
to speak about this subject,
and that was intentional.
- A lot of this stuff
that's happening on colleges in the movie,
you link it to how we've raised kids now.
So you wanna kick the
Millennials while they're down?
- I do.
I do as I travel
through this land.
I think the self-esteem movement
is really the genesis of this.
'Cause I started thinking, when I was 19,
I didn't have any self-esteem
and my thing was like,
I'm not gonna tell an adult what to do.
I would never dream.
If I was walking down
the street and I was 16
and I passed a 45-year-old
guy and he's going, hey, stop,
and I'd went, well, I need to go,
give me 20 push-ups,
I'd be a little, okay, with diamond hands
or we've gotta do a wide spread?
I would have just done it
because he's a dude and he's older than me
and he told me to do something.
That's how I was wired.
So I started thinking like,
well, if I were 19 and I
was on a college campus,
and I was on a construction site,
but if I was on a college campus.
And by the way, when I was
on a construction site,
I had a foreman go, he said,
"Go to my truck, get my four-foot
level out of my gun rack."
He had a four-foot level
hanging on his gun rack.
And I said, "Okay."
And I started walking to the
truck and he goes, "Hey, run."
And I started running
'cause he told me to run,
'cause he's older than I am.
And before--
- And also that gun rack,
so it was probably wiser to follow him.
- Yeah, where's the gun?
(gun cocks)
Run!
- It probably was in all levels in their.
- Run serpentine!
So I started thinking,
if I was 19 and I was on a college campus
and they announced that some 50-year-old
with a bunch of degrees
was coming to speak,
I would never go, over my dead body.
I'd just be like, oh, okay, all right.
And then someone would go,
well, Adam, he's gonna talk
about stuff you disagree with.
And I'd go, well, he's 50
and has all the degrees
so I'm probably wrong.
And then someone would go,
dude, does he have the
right to speak here?
And I go, of course, it's not my campus!
Basically, this is a
four-year motel I'm living at.
I don't own the building.
Who?
No, that's not for me to.
And then if they went,
we're gonna go rally and make
'em create a human blockade.
I'd be like, why?
Just don't go to the show!
Well, I don't get it.
And I realize--
- Sort of like a sane, functioning person,
that's what you're saying.
You would have acted
like a human should be.
- Yeah!
Well, how high does your
self-esteem have to be to go,
not on my watch,
no way is David Rubin or,
I'm sorry, Jordan Rubin,
or Ben Shapiro, sorry--
- You're combining all these people.
- I combined 'em into one being.
- What a horrible transformer!
- Yeah, that's gonna be protested.
Why would that be my job?
Who am I to do that?
So if you think about what that takes,
that takes a life of grooming.
That takes a life of don't let
anyone tell you what to do.
You tell them what to do.
You're special, your opinion
matters, don't let anybody.
So the self-esteem movement
I believe is super dangerous.
How are you gonna put World War II,
get in a Higgins landing
craft and go hit Normandy.
19-year-olds with super high self-esteem,
you think they're getting in that thing?
You think they're gonna
rush a German pillbox?
- Oh yeah.
- Hell no!
No!
So this thing that we thought was good,
like hey, what if everyone
just felt really good about themselves?
That's good if you earn it.
If you just rub it on 'em,
that ain't earning it and
that's gonna lead to trouble.
- So if we go a little meta on that,
do you think that's actually by design?
Do you think that is just like,
it's just like Liberals
that wanted everybody to
feel good and it's just nice,
or do you think it was actually by design
by some bad actors that
pushed this stuff out there
to weaken all of the things
that the movie's about?
- I think it can be traced back
to a gentleman who's out of Los Angeles
who had an idea which is it was,
and I'll paraphrase,
but it's like some of
these inner-city kids
and some of these low-income kids
or single-parent kids and stuff,
they have low self-esteem.
Their dad abandoned them.
They don't feel good about themselves.
And if they felt good about themselves,
they would start excelling in school
and get outta gangs and
not be involved with crime,
so how do we get them to
feel good about themselves?
And it's like,
well, we can't get their
dad back in the house,
and we can't give 'em an A in calculus
when they're failing calculus,
we're just gonna start
telling 'em how good they are
and they'll feel good about themselves.
And what ended up happening
is it turns out criminals
have high self-esteem.
They didn't know it's a
unintended circumstance,
like I have a good heart.
It's basically all that
stuff of I have a good heart,
let's build big housing projects
and let people live in free in those
and we'll give 'em food and we'll level.
It's like, yeah,
you're fooling them.
- All sounds good.
- It all sounds good,
you have a great heart,
you've now ruined a group of people.
That's how you ruin people.
You give them things without earning it.
You give them food without earning it,
you give 'em housing without earning it,
or you give them self-esteem
without earning it.
If you don't earn it, it doesn't work,
it morphs into something bad,
and then comes back in
a weird vitriolic way.
- So one of the things I kept
thinking during the movie
is over the last couple of years,
since I've had all these people on.
I mean, so many of the people
in the movie have been in here
to discuss the very things
they're bringing up in the movie,
I've often thought, man,
I am overblowing this?
Am I just exaggerating?
Or am I just finding these random people,
Lindsay Shepard, this TA,
Wilfrid Laurier University in Canada
which I had never heard of before,
am I overblowing this?
And then the answer
always turned out to be no
because the next week,
there's somebody else that it happens to,
and the next week,
there's somebody else and the rest of it.
But were you ever worried about that,
that as you make this,
that it makes it feel like
it's bigger than it is?
Or do you really believe
that it is this big?
- I think when you endeavor to
do any kind of storytelling,
there's a balance between
making it compelling.
I'll give you an example
and then I'll circle back.
I've made other
documentaries about subjects
that have nothing to do with this,
and I made a documentary about Paul Newman
and his racing life and it's called
"Winning: The Racing Life of Paul Newman",
and your audience would enjoy it.
His partner, his teammate,
and his best friend and teammate
died at a race in Florida.
Paul was racing, he was racing.
Fitzie was his name, he died in the race.
He died, they think, because
he had a heart attack
when he was driving the car
and just never slowed down for turn three
and just plowed in the walls.
- Jeez.
- And died.
And when you're making the film,
I'm saying it's more dramatic
if he just never hit
the brakes on turn three
and gotten this horrific
accident and died.
Now, the truth is, he had
a heart attack, probably,
and died and then hit the
wall and died for sure
or broke his neck or whatever it is.
And as a filmmaker, I'm
like, I don't wanna lie
but I'd like to make this
dramatic so I took out the part
where he probably was
dead from the heart attack
and just said he went
down the straightaway,
he never braked for turn three,
he died when he hit the wall.
And so there's this thing
where it's like don't lie
but you're also making a film.
You're trying to entertain.
I think what's going on on
college campuses is bad.
I have 13-year-old twins.
I have reservations about
sending them to college,
and I do hear the stories,
and I don't like the stories.
But by the same token,
you're trying to make a film
that holds people's interest,
and the music swells,
and you take a little artistic license
and it's a dramatic shot
of the smoke burning in
slow motion and stuff.
And yeah, so of course, there's an element
of we are gonna massage it
like they do in theatrical
filmmaking as well.
It's speaking to the
same party of the brain.
You want people to sit up, pay
attention, and what-have-you,
and it's just a part of filmmaking.
So the answer is yes and yes.
I do think it's bad but also,
you take some artistic
license and ratchet it up.
- Right.
And you guys actually hit all that
because there are moments
where it's like my heart was tight,
like oh man, this is horrible,
and then a minute later, you're laughing.
So it does kinda feel that.
When you see people,
I thought there's an extensive portion
on what happened to Bret Weinstein
and his wife Heather at Evergreen.
And as I was watching it,
and I know Bret very well
now and we're good friends,
I was thinking like wow,
how did he not see this coming
as a Lefty professor at a Lefty school?
Did you think that at all about
how did these guys not see
that this thing was just
brewing all this time
until the day before the kids
are showing up with the
baseball bats on campus?
- I think there's a disconnect.
I've had this thought all the time.
This is a big thing with Dr. Drew.
It's like there's a whole
anti-smoking coalition.
So there's a anti-smoking coalition,
and we hate smoke, secondhand
smoke, third-hand smoke,
there's no place for smoke
and then somebody goes,
oh, okay, we now have vaping,
it's just a vapor with nicotine
which is inert with vapor
and that's basically
saying caffeine and water.
So good, we're happy now.
They go, no, no, let's outlaw that.
And you go, hold on, I
thought you didn't like smoke.
It's like, yeah, no, we don't want.
And you start to realize some
groups, like PETA's that way,
the anti-smoking people are that way.
There's a right version of that.
When I did "Loveline", it
was like Christian coalition.
They're against abortions.
Oh, okay, good.
Now, they have the morning-after pill.
And they go, yeah, we're against that too.
And you go, wait a minute,
that's gonna stop abortion!
So they go, yeah, we're
not down with that pill.
And you're like, wait, you hate abortions?
Yes.
There's a pill you can take
that stops that insemination.
It's like, yeah, we don't want that.
Like, okay.
So now I'm starting to
think you just want control.
- My favorite one of those is Peter Thiel
who's the openly gay billionaire.
Out Magazine wrote a piece on
him that he's not gay actually
because he's Conservative,
and that would trump his gayness.
- Right.
- They wanted to--
- I love it when they do it
with gay or black or anything.
Candace Owens, she's not
black anymore because--
- Not black.
- I love it.
I love the hypocrisy.
And I realize that the group,
the progressive movement,
if you really just take those two words:
progress and movement,
it's like this is saying,
we don't stop, bucko.
We keep rolling.
And so, I think like Weinstein,
guys like that go,
they take things at face value.
Like okay, they want a day
without black students.
Okay, I get it.
That's a tradition.
I see what they want,
they want this thing.
And it's like, no, they
don't want this thing.
They wanna keep going
and they wanna keep
telling you what to do.
And once they get what
they want for a while,
no one's ever appeased.
- Right.
We don't go, okay, we could move on, guys.
Time to move on, we're good.
- No, they go, who's next?
What's next?
What can we do?
So this day without a black student thing,
the worst thing you can do is
just go, okay, good for you,
we applaud that.
They go, oh, okay,
and then they go, wait a minute,
there's nothing to push against!
The man has basically endorsed this.
- Right.
And Bret, just for the record,
he did endorse it for a decade there.
He said if you guys don't
wanna come on this date
to protest what you view
as historic discrimination,
go ahead and do it.
- But then you get bored
with that because now--
- So then they ramped it up.
- You're not telling someone
what to do so now you ratchet it up,
and then Bret Weinstein is like,
he doesn't get it
'cause he's seeing it through
the eyes of a sane person.
Basically--
- That's all of our
fatal flaws in this, huh?
- Well, the reason the Twin
Towers are on the ground
is because we did a thing of like,
wait a minute, who would fly
an airplane into a building
if they were in the airplane?
You would parachute out of the airplane?
No, no, I'll be the pilot.
I'll be the first to hit
the building and we go,
well, no one would do that.
I could see 'em putting
a truck bomb and running
but they're not gonna go fly it in
while all of 'em are in the airplane
who's that?
See, we don't think that way.
That doesn't make sense to us.
You have to realize there's
a lot of people out there
that think in a way that
is totally different
than the way you think.
And by the way, when you think,
you think it's a universal thing
that when you say to me
some people don't like lasagna,
I go, get the fuck outta here.
- That can't be possible.
- That's not true,
everyone loves lasagna.
And they go, some people
don't care for it.
I go, no way.
Everyone loves lasagna.
So they don't think like I think,
and they don't like lasagna,
and I can't picture that.
- But you don't fly
a plane into their home.
- That first.
- That's what you're telling me.
- Exactly!
That's what I'm saying.
You're gonna fly a commercial
airliner into their home.
So I'm saying I think guys
like Bret Weinstein is saying,
well, I think logically,
and I love everyone,
and I'm open-minded, and I'm a Liberal,
so no one could go after me
after all I teach at this school
and people know my reputation
and I a little bit of a Jew-fro,
and I'm soft-spoken,
and I ride my Schwinn in everyday.
Come on!
This group's that going
after me, I'm them, man!
So he's thinking and
what he's not realizing
is that group can go after anybody
because they're never satiated.
There's no finish line.
They're just going to keep going.
- Has that sold you on
Conservatism more so now?
I still describe myself as Liberal
but I see this as the real,
almost unsolvable problem of Liberalism,
that Liberals always want to be open
and decent and understanding
and all of that,
but then when a movement that
is so totalitarian and crazed
and wants to progress no matter
what it's progressing to,
Liberals don't seem to have
a good defense against that
where Conservatives seem
to actually have it better.
- I've never felt it practical
to pick a team
and then pick all that is that team.
I'll answer it in a roundabout way.
I love cars, I have a bunch of race cars,
I drive a bunch of race cars.
I have a lot of different
cars because I love cars.
Sometimes, I'll talk to guys and I'll go,
oh, they'll go, you're a
car guy, I'm a car guy.
You love cars, I love cars.
And then I go, what
kinda cars do you like?
And they go, I'm a Mopar guy.
Everything I got's a Dodge.
Everything's got a Hemi in it.
And I'm like, well, you're a car guy
but you just have this one car.
It's kinda like going,
I love the ladies but only Puerto Ricans.
It's like, why not hop on a blonde
and a black chick and a redhead?
If you really love women,
what's wrong with all of 'em?
That's my thing, it's like,
if you really love women,
go out with a whole
bunch of different women.
And I feel--
- Now, I finally believe
you're not racist.
- Ah, thank you.
- There you go,
you're willing to bang
every type of woman.
You're a good man.
- Every type of woman.
I treat my world politically,
like I'm just pushing a
cart through a Trader Joe's,
like I'm not really into
the Nilla cookies over there
but I do like that jerky.
At some point, the cart
will start to take shape
and you'll go, oh, this guy likes his meat
or he likes his protein,
or this person likes their
carbohydrates or whatever.
And so for me, it's like conservative.
Well, I'm not religious.
I'm basically an atheist.
And I'm not a gun person
but I'm not anti-gun.
I'm pragmatic gun.
I've realized
when you read op-eds in
The Los Angeles Times
about should we arm the teachers,
what difference would it make
if one of those teachers
at Columbine had a gun?
And then they go,
three kids dead, eight kids
dead, 15, what's the difference?
I'm like, what's the difference?
The difference is three
versus 15, imbecile!
I think it'd make a pretty big difference
to the fourth kid who would have died
if the teacher wasn't armed,
so it's like I'm not buying
into this cockamamie doctrine
of what difference would it make.
But my thing is like,
I'm not religious
and I don't have real strong
Conservative whatever,
upbringing or values,
but I do understand that intact families
and a focus on education
and having a patriotic.
The patriotic part, just
loving your country,
not to the point
where you've covered
yourself in the American flag
and driving a pickup truck,
but appreciating your country,
going, yeah, okay, we've made mistakes
but you know what,
is there anywhere else you'd rather live?
That leads to a happiness.
Pot, legal, gay marriage,
legal, whatever else,
do our own thing.
I'm very interested in
if I'm not hurting you,
I should be able to do what I wanna do.
But the problem with the
Left is the Left is saying,
let us tell you what to do.
And if you say something
that we have not vetted or approved,
we shall remove you from your job.
And that kind of McCarthyism
of no one can work
because you had a transgression
from 11 years ago in a
yearbook or whatever it is,
I don't like.
And the part that I really don't like
and the part that's feeling
very like Communist China to me
is the forced apologies.
That's the scary part to me.
The announcer that is talking about
the Baltimore Ravens quarterback,
and it's like, well,
his skin tone is dark,
the ball is dark, that jersey's dark,
he has an advantage.
And then at some point, he has to go,
I regret saying and realize
that my hurtful terms.
It's like, you don't regret it.
Those weren't hurtful terms.
We want you to analyze football
and you've actually brought up
a point I've never thought of
which is it takes a millisecond
for the outside linebacker
who's coming around the corner,
you're trying to get him
to bite on this play fake.
You're trying.
If I was a African-American boxer
and I had brown gloves
and I kept them close to my chest,
and you had red gloves,
I'd have a little advantage.
I could see the red gloves coming
a millisecond off of
versus the brown gloves
off of the brown skin color.
And this guy was
basically making the point
that at the defensive end,
and then he went on to say
how great the quarterback was.
So he's making a point,
it's an interesting point, and he's right.
The guy does a great
job of staying with it,
the ball is hard to spot,
the outside linebacker bites on it,
and he goes around him for a touchdown
and he has to pretend to apologize
because he's gonna get fired.
And when I hear,
to me, the heartbreaking
part of the whole thing
is the apology.
The outrage culture and all that,
it's the person with
the prepared statement
begging for you not to
relieve them of their job.
That's the part that
feels like Twilight Zone,
wish you out to the cornfield,
like hey, it's a good thing!
It's a real good thing, boy!
It's a good thing you did.
Everyone's scared to get
wished out into the cornfield
and now they're having to apologize.
- And there's so many
crazy examples of that.
Remember when Mark Duplass,
who's a Hollywood producer and
actor who's been on my show,
we're friendly and he sent out that tweet
that he basically said Ben
Shapiro is not the devil,
and then he had to apologize.
He didn't endorse the guy.
He didn't say he agreed with him.
It was in effect like he's
not a horrible person.
And then mom comes--
- It's like Orwellian,
but it's also McCarthyism.
Look, I know the Duplass brothers.
They're good guys.
- Yeah!
He's totally a good guy!
- They wanna work.
They wanna work.
Now, the only way to stomp this out
is for everyone to tell everyone
to fuck off and not do it
but Mark Duplass does shows with HBO.
They're very woke.
This may not hurt him
but are you taking that chance?
You got a production company,
wife and kids, employees,
you got a business.
And what he's doing is he's going,
me saying Ben Shapiro is a good guy,
even if I preface it
with you may not agree
with me politically.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, the whole, yeah.
- And whatever, and then
getting a bunch of blow-back,
maybe HBO does something about that.
- It's like what you said before.
- Maybe they don't.
I have 25 employees, do
I wanna take that chance?
I don't wanna take that chance
so I'm just gonna issue
this cowardly statement
basically distancing myself
from a guy who helped me out.
It's completely disingenuous.
It's cowardly.
But hey, I got a job.
I gotta keep my job.
This is what's great.
So now, you and I don't have that,
or maybe it's not helping you or I.
I don't know, I don't care.
But if you wanna work for HBO,
you wanna sell product to HBO,
you better be careful what you say,
who you associate with,
and who you do business
with, or who you praise.
- All right, so the last thing
so we can wrap up with the movie.
- Oh yeah.
- You talked about that Prager guy before.
There's a fun moment in the movie
where you talk about how
different you guys are.
Just everything about you,
you just said you're basically an atheist,
he's a, at least, somewhat religious Jew,
you're upbringings are
completely different.
Everything about you guys
are completely different,
yet you guys came together on this thing,
and you were touring in colleges
before this and all that.
Can you just talk about that a little bit?
- Well, I think we do a thing which is--
- You see how I brought it around
so that you could promote the movie?
- I do love that.
- Wasn't that professional
as an interviewer?
- "No Safe Spaces"
in theaters this week.
- .com.
You can also go to Chassy, C-H-A-S-S-Y.com
and see all these motor
racing docks I've made
if you like that.
I don't like this world.
I was just talking about this yesterday
where it's like we need diversity,
and people of color,
and the fire department
should represent the community
than it that it serves,
and it's all that,
and it's like, well,
so what your skin color
is the same color?
What really is that you're the same?
Dennis and I have common sense.
He has buckets of common sense.
I'm very rooted in common sense.
We have nothing in common
but we do have common sense,
and that trumps everything.
And we have somehow constructed
a world where you go,
your mom's name is Dorothy?
My mom's name is Dorothy!
Oh, wow!
Now we really have a bond.
Do you have a bond and you go,
you're from Valley Village?
I grew up in Valley!
So what?
You don't have a bond.
Your skin color, that
doesn't give you a bond.
Your height, you love,
oh, the Rams are your team?
I love the Rams!
What the hell kinda bond is that?
The real diversity is
having different thoughts
and different ideas,
and the real kinship
is sharing common sense
and ideas and in thinking alike.
Obviously, nobody could date further away
from my background than Dennis Prager.
He is a devout Jew, speaks five languages,
traveled to every continent in the world
and most every country,
is a scholar, is everything.
I'm from 4 1/2 miles that way,
grew up riding BMX bikes
and working on construction sites,
working as a boxing coach,
took groundlings classes,
there's no education, no
understanding of symphonic scores,
no anything except for
we have a total kinship
because with this common sense clarity,
I think I would count you
in that group as well.
I'm sure you and I are extremely different
in our upbringing, in our lifestyle,
but I feel it, a definite
clarity and a kinship with you
because of that common sense clarity.
And I think people make
a mistake where they go,
oh, well, you're just a Republican
or you're just a this,
or you're just a that.
No.
To me, people think clearly
or they don't think clearly.
It doesn't mean they're
right 100% of the time,
it's that they wanna get to it.
Famously, when you were sitting down
with Larry Elder all those years ago.
- Uh-oh.
- And they were
talking about race.
- Here we go.
- And he brought up a bunch
of stats and facts and stuff.
You didn't say cut,
you didn't say I agree to disagree,
you didn't do that
thing where you go like,
oh yeah, I'm gonna pull the real stats
and I'll get back to you Monday
and you'll apologize to me
and then never get back doing whatever,
you stopped and went,
"Well, maybe there's something I can learn
"from this person, and
I will be open to it."
And I was like, now I respect you.
I respect you.
And so in this conversation
where Larry Elder's shooting out
all these facts and figures,
I find myself respecting you.
I'm saying because he's open to this,
he's not going, oh, that
sounds like it's wrong,
he's going, I will leave myself
in this receptive position,
and if I hear things that make sense,
I'll think about it.
I'm not gonna ward off of everything
because you're on that
side and I'm on this side.
- It's funny, I just thought
that's what you're
supposed to do as a human.
It's not rocket science.
I just thought, oh, someone's
telling me something.
This stuff sounds pretty
good, I'll check it out,
and that was it!
- I always love when Prager says,
I don't need agreement,
I just need clarity.
I need to understand what you're saying
and you need to understand
what I'm saying.
And usually,
if you're both intelligent
people, you'll arrive.
And if there's not a
bunch of underlying issues
about being in with the
school teachers' unions
or something like that,
you'll just all arrive at the same place.
Yes, that's how you're supposed to be,
that's how you should be.
It's called being intellectually honest.
And I wish more people
on the Right and the Left were that way.
And it would behoove you to be that way
because that's the way you
grow and change and evolve.
- All right, cool.
I've never done this
in the history of "The Rubin Report" ever
but I'm gonna let you close
the show because you're a pro.
I want you to look at
that camera right there,
the one that's pointed towards you,
tell them about "No Safe
Spaces", where they can go.
It's in theaters now, the whole spiel.
I'm gonna be quiet for the rest.
Take it away.
- It's in 200 theaters as we speak.
It's nationwide as we speak.
It's 99% on Rotten
Tomatoes with the people,
or it's the critics.
Some haters in there.
- That's a mark of a good thing though.
- It is.
You can go to
NoSafeSpaces.com and find it.
And really take your kids.
Take the wife, take the husband,
take the husband and the wife,
but take the 13 and
14-year-old sons and daughters
and let 'em know what's
going on out there.
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling
you get everywhere else,
check out our comedy playlist.
And if you wanna watch full interviews
on a variety of topics,
check out our full episode playlist.
They're both right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.